Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Introduction to Unreal Motion Graphics
in Unreal Engine 5 for Programmers.
In this talk, we're gonna look at the following topics.
We're gonna look at UWidget and the user widget.
We're gonna look at the widget blueprint editor
and widget animations.
From there, we're gonna look
at widget overrideable functions
and some special UProperties specifies
that we have available.
From there, we're gonna take a look
at the widget component
and the widget interaction component.
Finally, we'll wrap up by looking at a live example
of a UI element created in UMG
that's built on top of our previous example
from the gameplay talk
and it will implement a lot of the principles
that we introduce in the following presentation.